Planning is another process central to cognition.
It is central because action selection is central to cognition. You and
I are constantly faced with the problem of selecting actions.
Where should I go for dinner today? What should I cook for dinner today? How do
I cook what I wanted to cook? I got a bonus. What should I do with the bonus?
Shall I go for a vacation? How should I go to a vacation?
Where should I go to a vacation? These are all problems of action selection. And
I need planning to select the appropriate actions.
Cognitive agents also have multiple goals. As a professor, one of my
goals right now is to talk with you. Another goal that I have is to become rich,
although I know that becoming a professor is not going to make me rich.
The point is that cognitive agents have multiple goals that can
have interactions between them. Sometimes interaction is positive.
Achieving one goal provides an opportunity for achieving the second goal.
Sometime the interaction is negative, there are conflicts. Cognitive agents
detect those conflicts. They avoid those conflicts. And planning, then,
is a central process for achieving multiple goals at the same time.